we are learning troubling new details of
how the pandemic is affecting female
workers this is serious in september
four times more women than men left the
workforce
according to the national women's law
center and a new study
by mckinsey and company and lenin.org
warns that the crisis could erase
all the gains that women have made in
recent years in the workplace
the women in the workplace report says
when one in four women is considering
leaving their job or downshifting their
career
because of the pandemic we spoke with
three women who recently left a job
and i never thought i would have to
leave my job
i had a lot of anxiety i was not
sleeping at night
because i was so worried i was the
general warehouse associate
when kovit first came out we were not
six feet apart
it was very unsafe
[Music]
i have a one-year-old she has breathing
issues and i also have a
year old she has a rare type of cancer
and so i i really had to leave my job
because of them
my kids are way more important than this
job i was working two jobs
one was doing medical and scientific
communications it was my dream job
and then the other was the freelance job
when i was working the two jobs and i
started a
covert response project and was
delivering food to frontline workers it
was all too much i was
you know going to bed at 3 or 4 a.m i
chose to let my main job
go i was a third grade teacher i
decided to quit my job because i didn't
feel comfortable putting my
four and a half month old in daycare
with coven
almost bud for getting there it's just
human nature
as a mother to want to do what's best
for your family
and if that means taking a step back to
ensure safety then i think that's a
decision that many
would make if it's possible
[Music]
rachel thomas is co-founder and ceo of
leanin.org and lorena lee
is the chief diversity and inclusion
officer at mckinsey
and company they both helped write this
report that we're talking about this
morning
and rachel i want to go to you first we
just heard from a mother who left her
job
to spend time with her children to be
there for her children
that's actually really common and so the
question comes to mind
what do companies need to do to support
these women also what a spouse's
partners need to do what does society
need to do companies are taking steps to
support women right now but the problem
is they're not doing enough to address
the crux of the issue which is burnout
women cannot be expected to live up to
businesses usual expectations right now
nobody can so what does that look like
companies need to start asking some
tough questions
were goals set before the pandemic are
they attainable and realistic now
should performance reviews look like
they did before the pandemic probably
not
and companies also need to set new norms
for how they're working
so perhaps no emails after 8 pm at night
we know that women and
all employees feel like they're on 24 7
right now
and companies need to address that head
on yeah lorraine
i want to go to you because the pandemic
coincided with this national
conversation about racial justice
and i was interested in the report to
learn that only one in three women of
color say they heard from a manager
about how they might be doing
does that number surprise you it doesn't
surprise me quite frankly because even
before covid there were huge disparities
for women of color
we know that women of color and
particularly black women had fewer
opportunities
had fewer mentors and sponsors and when
they looked up
at corporate america they saw fewer
people that looked like them
and could be role models for them and
then what happened with kovid
we saw that black women for instance saw
three times more likely
to face the death of a loved one and
felt more uncomfortable
sharing that and we didn't see managers
step up just as you said
well so i i say i was surprised that it
was only one out of three managers but
on the other hand i'm also not surprised
because i think uh you know particularly
for managers white particularly manager
is male they may not be sure
how to reach out they may find it risky
they're not sure what language to use
so what advice do you have for how
managers can make that call have that
conversation that they
themselves may find a little difficult
oh it's such a great question and it's
really important because if you
step up to be an ally it actually
matters a lot
we know that black women who had an ally
over the course of the pandemic are two
and a half times more likely
to see a fair workplace and to want to
stay and feel encouraged and motivated
so being an ally stepping up and
speaking out
and asking the basic question of what is
going on in your life and let me be
there let me understand and let me make
sure you still have opportunities in the
workplace
yeah rachel i want to jump back to you
you know one of the amazing things
that's happening right now
is that it's not just women who are in
their first position that are leaving
but women in senior roles who are
mid-career or even later
they're stepping back and that's a loss
because the kind of chain
of success is broken those women are
likely to be mentoring other women
how do you keep those women in those
jobs what do companies need to do to say
hey hey stick around i know it's hard
now but we need you
yeah bernard is the crux of this for a
lot of women so what we know
are senior leaders are facing a lot
right now they're running businesses
that are sometimes failing
employees are struggling and senior
level women are facing the same
stressors as senior level men
but then some they feel like they need
to work harder
they're more likely to be burned out and
they're more likely to think about
leaving the workforce and as you said we
cannot afford to lose senior level women
when there's more women in leadership
companies perform better they have
better cultures
and back to that mentorship and allyship
that lorena was just talking about
we know that senior level women are more
likely to show up for women of color
as allies mentors and sponsors so we
cannot afford to lose senior level women
organizations need to be doubling down
to make sure they feel supported
if leaders don't feel supported it's
hard for them to bring their best selves
and the empathy they need to make sure
other employees are getting the support
they need right now
lorena we're running out of time but
there's an important question i want to
get to uh to you in particular
california passed a law recently
requiring boards to have at least one
woman
and now even more recently the governor
of california
signed a law requiring those boards to
have a person of color i think it was an
executive director position
do you think quotas like that which
don't make it just a duty but a legal
responsibility are a good idea a good
way to reach these goals
well we've had quotas in europe before
and i think it's not so much the issue
of a quota per se
but do companies have clear targets and
goals
are you actually being specific about
what success looks like it's not just
more women
how many women and at what time period
and if you're not clear on your goal
how do you expect the rest of the
organization to fall suit
we know what gets measured gets watched
and what gets measured
gets done and as rachel said we also
know that diversity at the top
level of a management team and a board
creates better business performance
so why would you say no to that yeah
it's a good question companies sent
goals for everything else they put
numbers on it so why not put a number on
this
rachel thomas and lorena yee thank you
very much for being here guys
very important report